الى مراسلنا في جنين سمير ابو شماله سمير
اذن الغضب عارم في مختلف الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والحاله خاصه في جنين وهي مسقط
راس الشيخ خضر عدنان ضعنا في المشهد لديك
[موسيقى]
نعم نحن بطبيعه الحال الان وصلنا الى امام
منزل الشهيد الشيخ خضر عدنان في بلده
عرابه جنوب غربيه مدينه جنين حيث هناك
حاله من الغضب والاحتقان الشديد بين اوساط
الفلسطينيين الذين يتجمعون في محيط هذا
المنزل في هذه البلده وهناك في هذه
اللحظات هناك كلمات تابينيه من اصدقاء
ومحبي الشيخ عبد خضر عدنان وايضا كان هناك
زملاء له في الاسر الاسرائيلي الذين ايضا
خاضوا معارك الامعاء الخاويه في داخل
السجون الاسرائيليه على سبيل المثال قبل
قليل انهى الاسير المحامي محمد علان كلمه
ابنيه
خاصه بالشيخ خضر عدنان وقبله بذلك كانت
زوجه الشهيد الشهيد خضر عدنان التي اكدت
بانها هي فخوره جدا باستشهاد زوجها في
المعتقل الاسرائيلي وانها ماضيه هي
واولادها التسعه طريق الشهاده وايضا في
طريق النضال والنصر لتحرير فلسطين على
طريق ما كان يصبو اليه الشيخ خضر عدنان
على مسيره نضاله في هذه السنوات او في
السنوات الاربعين الذي قضاها في هذه
الحياه وبالتالي
زوجه الشهيد ايضا اكدت بانها طالبت الجهات
الدوليه والمؤسسات الدوليه بضروره تسليم
جثمان زوجها وايضا دون ان يخضع لاي عمليات
تشريح من قبل سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
بشكل عام الاوضاع وحاله الغضب والاحتقان
الشديده في الاوساط الفلسطينيه هي جاءت
على المستوى الرسمي وايضا الشعبي
والجماهير والفصائل التي اكدت ودانت هذه
الجريمه التي وصفت بجريمه اغتيال وايضا
جريمه اعدام بدم بارد من قبل سلطات
الاحتلال الايطاليه واداره مصلحه السجون
الاسرائيليه التي
فرطت فيها الشيخ الشهيد خضر عدنان والتي
لم تقدم له العلاج الطبي المناسب وايضا
رفضت الافراج عنه حسب ما تم تقديمه من
طلبات من قبل المحاميه في الجلسات التي
كانت تعقد والتي كان اخرها الاحد الماضي
والتي رفضت المحكمه الاسرائيليه الافراج
عنه واجلت النظر في هذه القضيه في العاشر
من الشهر الحالي ولكن شهاده الاستشهاد
الشهيد او الشيخ خضر عدنان هو قد قطع
الطريق على هذه المحكمه التي رفضت الافراج
عنه هناك دعوات كثيره من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وهناك حاله حداد واضراب عام
وشامل في جميع المحافظات الفلسطينيه وايضا
بما في ذلك مدينه القدس المحتله هناك حاله
من الغضب والحزن الشديد في داخل منزل
الشهيد خضر عدنان والذي امته وتوافد اليه
الكثير من النساء وايضا الشبان الذين
يتجمعون في محيطين هذا المنزل في حاله
صدمه من قبل
هذه السياسه الممنهجه من قبل سلطات
الاحتلال الايطاليه باتجاه الاسرى
الفلسطينيه والتي كان اخرها استهداف او
ترك الشهيد خضر عدنان يصارع الموت في كل
لحظه حتى نال الشهاده في هذه في هذه
الفجره فجر هذا اليوم في احدى الزنازين في
داخل سجن الرمله وبالتالي اسرائيل تمارس
هذه السياسه وهي سياسه الاهمال الطبي
وايضا عمليه التعنت في طلب او في رفض
طلبات الافراج عن هؤلاء الاسرى الذين
يعانون من حالات صحيه خطيره هناك المئات
من داخل في داخل السجون الاسرائيليه
يعانون من امراض مزمنه وامراض متفاوته في
داخل الاسره الاسرائيليه ولكن لا يقدم له
العلاج المناسب واللازم
من قبل سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليات هناك
جامعات وبالتحديد الجامعه التي كان قد هو
كان خريجا من جامعه بيرزيت الشيخ خضر
عدنان في الرياضيات الاقتصاديه والتي نعت
الشيخ خضر عدنان واعتبرته ابنها الشهيد
وصفاته بابنها الشهيد وايضا هناك جامعه
النجاح الوطنيه وبالتنسيق مع نقابه
العملية وايضا مع اداره الجامعه ومجلس
الطلبه ايضا علقوا او اضربوا في هذه
المؤسسه التعليميه اضافه الى المدارس
التعليميه الحكوميه والخاصه التي
اعاده الطلاب الى منازلهم وذلك استنكارا
وتنديدا بهذه الجريمه التي افاق عليها
الفلسطينيون فجر هذا اليوم باستشهاد الشيخ
خضر عدنان وهو احد القيادات البارزه في
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي والتي كانت تتهمه
سلطات الاحتلال في لائحه الاتهام الاخيره
وفي القضيه الاخيره بانه هو كان يساعد على
التحريض ويستخدم الوسائل جميع الوسائل
للتحريض على الاحتلال وايضا الاش عضويته
لتنظيم محظور وهو حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
ولكن الشيخ خضر عدنان كانه دائما حاضرا في
جميع الميادين التي كانت ترعى ايضا تساند
وتدعم الحركه الاسيره والاسرى الفلسطينيون
داخل السجون الاسرائيليه والتي ايضا اليوم
قبل قليل كان هناك بيان من لجنه لجنه
الطوارئ العليا للحركه الاسره في داخل
السجون الاسرائيليه بحاله الاستنفار العام
ورفض او رجاع جميع وجبات الطعام
من قبل من قبلهم لسلطات الاحتلال وذلك
انحدادا والاستنكارا لهذه الجريمه الجديده
التي
يتعرضها يتعرض لها الاصاب الفلسطينيون
هناك كان حاله استنفار ايضا في سجن عوفر
العسكري عند العسكري عندما
عندما يعني هاجم احد السجناء احد السجانين
في بعد الاعلان عن استشهاد الشهيد استشهاد
الاسير خضر عدنان اذا كما نلاحظ هناك
هتافات حاليا كان هناك بصبيحه اليوم ايضا
كان مسير عفويه قد خرجت في هذه البلده
وشوارع هذه البلده وتقدمها نجل الشهيد خضر
عدنان وهو حمزه التي صدح بها بحنجرته
الصغيره هتافات كانت غاضبه وتندد باستشهاد
الشيخ خضر عدنان في هذا اليوم بدلا من ان
يكون على مقعد دراسته ولكنه كان محمودا
اليوم ليهتف باسم والده الذي اعلن عن
استشهاده فجرا هذا اليوم المؤسسات المؤسسه
الرسميه الرئيس الوزراء الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه الحكومه الخارجيه حملت
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تداعيات هذه الجريمه
والمسؤوليه الكامله عن هذه الجريمه التي
وصفت بجريمه اغتيال بحق الشيخ خضر عدنان
وقد طالبت الوزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
ايضا سترفع هذا الملف الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وطالبت بضروره تفعيل
وتشكيل لجنه تحقيق دوليه للتحقيق في
ملابسات هذه الجريمه الجديده التي تضاف
الى مزيد ملف الجرائم المستمره بحق الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في داخل السجون الاسرائيليه
او في حق الفلسطينيين في خارج هذه السجون
الذين يتعرضون بشكل على مدار الساعه بشكل
يومي لهذه الجرائم وهذه الملاحقات
والاعتقالات والمداهمات والاقتحامات
للبلدات والمدن الفلسطينيه والتي هي ايضا
تصفر عن مزيد او سقوط المزيد من الشهداء
والجرحى وايضا الاعتقال للفلسطنين وزجهم
في
المعتقلات الاسرائيليه هناك ايضا
منظمات حقوقيه وايضا نادي الاسير وزاره
الشؤون الاسرى والمحررين كلها جميعا اعتبر
هذه الجريمه هي جريمه مكتمله الاركان
وايضا هي جريمه مع سبق الاصرار والترصد
بحق الشيخ خضر عدنان الذي كان يعاني
ويصارع الموت في كل لحظه خلال فتره اضرابه
التي وصلت الى 87 يوما داخل الاسهم
الاسرائيلي